what happens when a soldier has no
orders it's Sunday which means Doctor
Who and it's Big Finish which means that
my patreon sport has got to select this
one so this time I'm taking a look a
look a listen at Jubilee this is a Sixth
Doctor adventure written by Robert
Sherman and that already have me pretty
excited because he wrote the Holy Terror
which was another Sixth Doctor audio
adventure and has so far been my
favorite of the Big Finish audio dramas
that I've listened to yes even more than
spare parts
although spare parts probably better
jumping on point uh in any case this had
pretty high expectations for me doubly
so because I knew that this was an
influence on one of the best episodes of
the show which is the series 1 episode
Dalek Robert Sherman wrote that as well
and it was in many ways an adaptation of
this story of this audio so I'll avoid
spoiler I'll talk about general premise
but I'll avoid spoilers for a while
because I know not nearly as many people
watch the or listen to the Big Finish
has watched the show so I can't I can't
count on people having having heard this
so this is the sixth doctor and he is
traveling with a companion named Evelyn
Smythe who is a character I knew about I
was aware of
I hadn't encountered her yet and had
heard good things about her so she is a
little she's a bit older then companions
tend to be she is a history she's a
historian a history buff person that's
that's kind of her whole thing and what
happens is that she and the doctor
basically through a little bit
of accidental time little messing up
there ends up being an alternate history
to the history we know so that what
happens is in 1903 the Daleks invaded
earth and the doctor helps stop them but
what happened after that was that
Britain the British Empire kept
expanding they actually reclaimed
America they you know that they are they
are an empire and so when we pick up on
the story we've obviously we've got the
doctor we've got
evylyn and but then we've got this
character of the president of England or
Britain possibly says I can't remember
now his wife who is a almost parody
level sort of Oh silly old me you know
sort of thing we've got there's a guard
named lamb who we deal with there's a
guy who seems to be kind of a
high-ranking official whose name is
suddenly escaping me and and the doctor
and evil and just sort of come in and
try and figure out what's going on how
did it get this way can we fix it and it
just goes from there and it's
interesting
coming into this because in some ways it
deals in a lot of similar things to what
went on and Holy Terror not in the core
of the story the the overall core and
central premise is very different but a
lot of the accoutrement a lot of the
extra stuff going on as well is very
similar there's a lot going on with
characters who you know appear to be one
way and kind of have another thing going
on but not like in a secret agenda way
just you know you have characters who
seem very outwardly to be easy to peg
and then you get revealed of oh no the
it's not what's going on with you so
that that sort of things that play again
there's a lot of very cutting satire in
regards to government and just how
people come to be in positions of power
and how especially I think most
pointedly how we as a society treat the
worst parts of our own history and how
we framed them when revisiting and
looking back on that history and I I do
think I can I can mention this without
getting his boys because this introduced
basically immediately and actually in a
sequence that I thought was like a
trailer for another another Big Finish
audio it actually starts with the
trailer for a movie like Donna the
doctor the ultimate adventure which is a
trailer for the movies that are shown in
the society about the doctor defeating
the Daleks and it's very it very
deliberately parallels the way that
Nazis have been treated in entertainment
and how they've kind of become marketed
to a certain degree I think thankfully
we're we're hitting a point where that's
that's easing back and because that mean
this was predictive in a lot of ways
this this this audio is this is over 15
years old I think so but it like it
pulls very specifically they give the
the doctor in this trailer thing you
know a lot an Indiana Jones line you
know from Indians less crusade he has
the line Nazis I hate these guys they
gave him that line but he just says
Daleks I hate these guys and it makes it
very clear how the sort of turning the
worst monsters of history into a kind of
commodity has impacted our society in
the way we view
evil and it's it's dealing with a lot of
big ideas and dealing with them quite
well much in the same way Holy Terror
was dealing with a lot of big ideas and
dealt with them really well Robert
Sherman I'm I'm continuing to be really
really impressed now next thing I'm
gonna say I'm gonna call this mildly
spoilery because depending on how well
you know the episode Dalek I'm gonna
refer to some of the similarities and
differences and that will kind of
indicate for you some of the stuff going
on and Jubilee but again if you know one
is adapted from the other you probably
already know all this so to say that the
episode Dalek the the ninth a doctor
episode called Dalek is an adaptation of
Jubilee is true but kind of doing it a
disservice because this this audio is
over two hours Jubilee is about forty
four Daleks about forty four minutes do
you believes over two hours so there's a
lot more going on here than in Dalek and
that's not a knock on Dalek Daleks is a
terrific episode but really Dalek is a
single subplot of Jubilee getting the
getting the focus for 45 minutes because
there is a captured Dalek and it is
being tortured by its human captors they
really want it speak it has some of the
similar interactions with the doctor it
has a similar sort of bond that it forms
with the doctor's companion in this case
it's it's evylyn and in the show it was
rose but most of that is pretty similar
like not exact it's not beat for beat
but that that thing that was the
entirety of Dalek is just one of maybe
three of the main story threads going on
in in Jubilee so even if like you
thought I don't think I'll get that one
because I
I already know it because I know the
episode dolly you don't there's a lot
more going on and I didn't like it more
than holy terror
I'm holy terrorist still my favorite but
this was really good and I'm I like I'm
enjoying the Sixth Doctor in audio as
much as I am because boy him and him in
the show just oh boy don't know if you
saw my review for the two doctors but
ouch anyway getting more into sort of
proper spoilers there's a lot of really
good small touches throughout this I
like that they very much hint at like
spoilers coming like series that's your
last warning I like that they hint at an
appearance of Davros and it turns out
just to be an older alternate version of
the doctor because you know there's all
this talk about a wheelchair and there's
a mention of you could say he created
the Daleks and it turns out it's just
the an older version of the doctor who's
been captured for a hundred years and
they cut his legs off because he kept
trying to escape and that's why he's in
a wheelchair
in terms of similar things to what I
said was going on in holy terror they
kind of do a similar thing with somebody
who isn't evil enough by another
person's measure because you have the
the president who's kind of a
fascinating character who on the surface
is the tyrant you know ordering people
to death he strikes his wife but then
his wife is upset that he didn't hit her
hard enough to break the skin so you
have this very twisted relationship
going on between the two of them which
is in sick hey if we're being honest but
it's interesting and it works you know
for the purposes of drama and I found
the President himself to be a really
interesting character and I think again
a really good sort of pointed
satirize ation sort of just really
singling something out because he is
someone who does awful things all the
time but it's very obsessed with the
idea that deep down he's a good man that
you know people can't know he's a good
man because they'll you know then then
they won't be afraid of him and any
won't hold power and or they'll kill him
or what have you so he keeps
rationalizing oh I don't want to do
these things as he sentenced as a family
to death I don't want to do these things
as he authorizes the torturing of the
Dalek no but I have to don't you see I'm
I'm a good man but I have to do these
awful things the rationalizations he's
gone through are impressive and do a lot
to deepen what otherwise could have been
a fairly generic slightly buffoonish
political character and I really enjoyed
his wife for similar reasons in terms of
the Miriam is her name in terms of the
levels going on with her because you
have your surface level which like I
said is this sort of bubbly giggly yeah
you know oh I'm just a silly old woman I
don't know anything about that sort of
thing and that's the surface level and
it's not hard to guess that there's
gonna be more going on with her than
that and so we find out she's planning
to overthrow her husband and she's
planning to stage a coup and take over
the government and she wants them to
stop torturing the doll I can you think
oh she's a she's the good revolutionary
character and you find out even more
about her she wants to be even bloodier
than her husband is and she wants them
to stop torturing the Dalek because she
wants the Dalek on her side killing
people that she thinks should die so the
the whole story does with a couple of
characters does this whole sort of oh
they're other this and now they're this
and you think oh okay well that was your
reveal and then there's another
underneath that which doesn't feel like
a cheat
it feels consistent which is actually
really tricky because when you do those
sort of multiple levels of reveal on the
nature of a character it can feel like
you cheated it can feel like you you
were just lying up to a point whereas
these feel like genuinely peeling back
layers and it's really well done like if
I'm being honest I think my only
complaint this has been this is probably
just me I don't like the bit in the
first episode where they're talking to
the Prime Minister of America because I
kind of hate British people mocking
American accents and I'm not like I'm
not saying that because I both ended I'm
not offended I just hate the way it
sounds it just it hurts me to listen to
so I don't like that but like that I
might be the only because I I have a I
have a suspicion that probably a fair
amount of British people or even
Anglophile Xin the u.s. like finite very
funny cuz they didn't go so far as to
give him like a Texan accent but he's
it's a very strong very potent ly
American accent but you know by someone
who very obviously doesn't naturally
have that and it's oh boy yeah the the
standard British person doing a mock
America nice and it just hurts my ears
man but that's that's super nitpicky and
it hardly ruined anything because he
only appears briefly in the first
episode that's kind of it
this is really good and there's the the
timey wimey the time mending nature to
it that's going on I think the one thing
that I think for instance that Dalek did
better was that at the end of Jubilee
evylyn destroys the Dalek using his own
gun and at his request
whereas in Dalek the Dalek self
destructs but he can't do that without
being ordered which is actually way more
consistent with a lot of the themes
going on because there's a lot of
emphasis that this Dalek what he wants
he doesn't even want to exterminate he
doesn't want to strike he just wants
orders because that's what his position
is and you can see the influence on not
only the episode Dalek but things like
the concept of Dalek Caan you know later
on you know the the the Dalek who has
gone mad
who has looked sort of down the line of
what the Daleks are and what they could
ultimately be and what that would mean
and sort of turning against them a
little bit so there's it's more than
just the template for the episode Dalek
you can see how it influenced other
decisions and other things that happened
later on I also want to take a minute to
talk about evylyn I liked her a lot I
she actually she reminds me of Donna a
little bit I think in terms of that
completely offered flirtatious
completely asexual slightly older woman
she kind of she's got it she's got a bit
of lip on her she's she feels like the
book-smart version of Donna whereas
Donna is the street-smart version that's
kind of how it feels and I like her I
like what I'm getting from her so I look
forward to running into her more in the
future and I think guy will wrap it up
on that note I haven't taken the the
vote from my patrons yet to know what
I'm doing next month but that'll be
happening soon you want to get on that
um any level of patron support you get
to vote in the polls for which classic
and Big Finish audios I will be tackling
on you know in future months so that'll
wrap it up you know the stuff you can do
you don't need me to tell you about it
there's links for the patreon and all
the other stuff that I'm involved in
it's all down in the description take a
look if you care and just remember folks
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]